hey what's happening thanks for tuning
in to another episode of left to be
talked to bitching files here brought to
you by earth quaker devices my sponsor
over two years making stompboxes foot
pedals rock and roll machines out of
Akron Ohio handmade awesome stuff
awesome people if you play guitar
immediately hit Oh earthquaker devices
calm or hit him on Instagram they're
doing all kinds of cool instagram stuff
lately or on twitter foam get yourself
sounding good man want to sound [ __ ]
badass on guitar bass or whatever get it
see ya all right how are you Spicer I'm
great dude my youngest turns one this
week tomorrow one we got a bunch of
family in town if you're listening live
right now instead of when this goes up
I'm gonna go see Louie tonight yeah
again is back baby at the store tonight
and man I can't even tell you how great
that is because like this guy could go
on anywhere yeah he could just call up a
VFW hahaha an elks club or Elks Lodge
anything and be like hey CK I want to be
on I want to do show tonight and you
know he chooses the store and he could
also choose like la life and be like
tickets are a hundred dollars yes I'm
working out new material but yeah people
will still come like he respects the art
and what he's working on and the
location where it happens a lot it's
it's you can tell you just loves the
comedy store which just gives the comedy
store more and more prestige across the
the social media platforms and it's just
great for us who are there every night
and we get the spill off of that people
come and you know when Louise not there
or in your burrow or
Aaron or Apatow or anyone they still
come and they and they have a great time
they're not like oh the big guys aren't
here they're like this place is great
and that's been the overall a word on
the street over the last year or so
people you see him in the hall there
like I love this place and you truly
don't that you know they market it as
like you never know who's gonna pop in
last night at potluck we're on white
showed up yeah and went up and just
crushed in like so me as a comic waiting
to get up I'm like ah I might not get up
now cuz Ron's gonna do more than you
know three to five minutes that everyone
else is doing but at the same time I'm
sitting here watching calling him a
legend implies that he's past his prime
which he's not but like watching one of
the people at the top of their game work
on [ __ ] yeah I don't like five feet away
from it like this is incredible I'm
fingers I don't think it's going to
happen but in my ideal world Chappelle
pops in tonight too well Sunday night he
popped in and did the the Don bear a
spot and went on till 3am insane amazing
he was in a sleeveless like like a
cutoff t-shirt just like I sun's out
guns out just working it out and I had
some friends that drove all the way from
healdsburg to come see the store and
what a good night I got him got him in
and they told a hilarious story where
they drove the guy's dream was to come
to the comedy store it's just always
hears about it sees the lineup snowing
yeah so they drive the first night and I
was talking to them and they go where'd
you standing over stayed in Bakersfield
last night I go why'd you stay there
like they're coming up the five just
stay at a motel six right off the five
yeah they went way off the beaten path
to Bakersfield stated some super 8 that
had roaches [ __ ] yeah like not the
zombies I'm is very good that might have
been meth roaches yeah
there were men but then they woke up
came to the store and they got to see
apatite went out first but they got to
see Apatow Dahlia who uh but you know
Chappelle yeah there's a bunch of great
people on that night uh who else was on
that anyway I can't remember it's just a
bore there every night right but anyway
they had an incredible time some glad
they came out yeah that's a good random
night to pick the Chappell night yeah
pretty awesome yeah I always love when
my favorite thing to watch is when
people don't know but you know yeah I
like to go to the room right away i
watch the dude bring it up so hey who's
next and they'll hand in a usually a
note on you know in the surprise yeah
and then i will open up and be like oh
oh well you do never know what who's
going to pop in here a Dave Chappelle
and then people's heads pop up well they
can't even believe it yeah like the whip
oh yeah it's fake to first yeah
sometimes there will be minimal claps
right like all right and then as soon as
they see him they all [ __ ] he's not
lying yeah yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious
so yeah tonight you're going to lose
your bring in your lady yep lady and I
hit and Louise the date night I mean it
is i guess you guys gonna do it after
Louie oh yeah i mean we're actually
gonna hopefully do it during Louie you
have to make eye contact with them and
that's my dream some people are gonna
head to room with a boner I really just
like I've been building this whole
stand-up comedy career just for tonight
to throw it all away that a hundred
percent Oh what I'm doing I don't I'm
not uh I think a lot of people do use
comedy night as like a precursor to
[ __ ] yeah it's it doesn't I love
comedy obviously but it doesn't doesn't
work that way for me I think after
tonight I'll be like in Amanda the same
way she loves Louie she was really into
his ease for a while he saw his ease i
love Aziz and after that we're both just
like oh my god yeah that was so great
that one bit and that love it knock it
out we eat pizza no point are we like
that was so great let's go [ __ ] it's
like yeah
and then he did that bit that we saw
from two years ago and tonight it worked
and we're both just like nerds on it
yeah yeah that's it man where other
people are just like you can see the
dudes in the audience and they're just
like looking at their girl the whole
time like yeah she's drunk yeah I got
you I got you into Louie yeah exactly
I'm not yeah Louie is so [ __ ] great
you wear suits now that's what you were
saying I haven't yeah i think i've seen
suited Louie in person so I'm excited
yeah well I want to ask him about that
you know like at what point did he say I
don't wear suits now or whatever you
place all bird dressing up in those ber
has like those killer dress shirts now
yeah and Louie was like I don't think
sober when we did the long beach terrace
theater / wore the most amazing suit
ever and I just came out in garbage cans
my clothes are not you know know you are
but just definitely not I know we paid
for a lot of them funny when you see
like BRR I think almost if a burr had
the most incredible suit fit perfect in
area doesn't matter what you're wearing
the killer suit just trumps yes SIA so I
am excited to see Louie in a suit burn a
suit i can imagine looks amazing cuz i'm
wearing this dress shirt yeah right
exactly yeah at some point these guys
are t-shirt dudes yeah and then I'll
sudden you saw borough start wearing
like nice shirts 90 more sneakers yeah
you know and it was a different thing
and same with Louie I wonder if it's
something about when you hit doing
theaters regularly cuz there's a weird
like if I'm at you know even like a
great showcase show in town and you see
like some I won't say kid but like you
know some comic appear of mine come up
in a suit I'd be like yeah what are you
doing yeah I do like a 90 stick well I
think it's a next level I and I think
what it really is this Ike and I respect
it they're like they're here for a show
yeah it's not when they're doing [ __ ]
15 right right you know we're not
talking about that yeah but when it's a
solid show night maybe a thirty forty
fifty hundred dollar ticket and it's a
theater or even the main room and it's a
night
Saturday night's sold-out they they they
show it some old school shut you know
like yeah look old-school showbiz you
know and I think that's a good point I'm
gonna think if your audience is getting
dressed up to see you like people like
doing it as a date night and guys and
girls are getting dressed up then it's
it's nice to have the performer also
treat it as such yeah you don't
necessarily have to have a suit to do
that like I've seen some of your jackets
right yeah I can fit sold out in the
main room I'll wear like a great jacket
you know what I mean I'm not I never go
on in a t-shirt anymore anyway it's
always like a nice flannel like my
purple rain right here yeah that's all
that last night not too high track yeah
saw your post dude purple rain in the
theater I know man first of all if you
don't live in LA we have this mystery
area that is just a [ __ ] garbage can
of la called century city yeah it really
has zero soul well it was this is not
based on anything but I feel like it's
the people that lived in Beverly Hills
yeah that got sick of commuting downtown
right we're just gonna build our own
downtown here and it's just skyscrapers
just like very just like black
skyscrapers in a very like blit
westfield mall or not you know director
Westfield but just like it's like a mall
here's green right so we like I was I
was saying last night if somebody I was
standing in front of the theater and I
was just looking at for skyscrapers and
I said if somebody just blindfolded
kidnapped me for a week and drop me off
there yeah and on that one spot I was at
they said where are you I would not be
able to name it and I live in this
[ __ ] sing for 13 years and I've been
here all my life I got good name I was
just looking at it to be fair one of
those skyscrapers is the nagatomi tower
from die hard oh well one of them's my
doctor yeah but that's what they got
there they got a couple dr. towers then
a very strange wells fargo tower another
tower that people live in i guess and in
this mall so it
my point is no one ever says man century
cities it's just it's where I live is
cool right would you ever say yeah which
isn't even cool yeah that's so weird how
that part of the city is soulless yeah
so I went there and saw a purple rain
and which by the way oh we got a call
and then I'll get into it cuz it's funny
story hey what's happening you're on the
air who's calling hey Dean and spicy
town what's going on this is a long time
no talk no deal Johnny here no deal
Johnny what's going on dude not much man
not much where are you calling from
again from Philly I'll Philly that's
right Philly Philly [ __ ] Phillies
better than century city how we just
talking about century city and then I
how are you bud you got a question today
ah no question really just wanted to
check in with you guys since I had some
time tonight cuz Tuesdays are usually
bad for me so I just want to say hi and
you know that's about it and I tweeted
you about it the other day about the
dweezil zappa situation oh yeah that's
that's a strange thing man I I said it's
a sick time Ballmer for me I mean I'd
I've been friends with him since you
know I've round the same time you said
you met him back in like 91 and I'm
actually going to see him tomorrow night
here in Philly show but yeah it's just a
whole weird dynamic man I always thought
that time we've so tight you know I
think people are tight until people
people die you know what's going on with
the Prince family right now so once
Gayle was gone because you know and also
hats off to I don't know anything about
the situation you know who knows what's
going on I just going off what i read
from what do we will post it but
apparently i'll let you people know
what's what he posted was he was no
longer allowed to use the zappa plays
zappa name anymore which is his
his name name and his father's name
which is made me steaming immediately
because as soon as I read it I went oh
this is some [ __ ] money [ __ ] here
and yeah it's a really complicated
situation because like even the last
name Zappa is copyrighted and write less
than yours what for the last 10 years
when he's been doing taco please after
he had to actually pay Gail money that's
what he said he didn't like baby mining
royalties on it well you know I got a
city I gotta say Dweezil is a very
classy man because I've known to weasel
four years of course he's not going to
tell me inner secrets and stuff but when
he was on the podcast not once did he
ever complain or say anything about it
and he only held up his family and the
highest highest light you know he talked
great about his his brothers and sisters
and his mom and as it is growing up in
his family and and you know that inside
he already knew that was going on you
know he's been going on for a while
right you know there was a time it was
around two thousand ten or so he there
was another dispute with the name where
he had to start using a different name
for a little while and I don't know if
he eventually gave in and started paying
more money or what the whole deal is and
I am I am NOT going to ask him about it
at all yeah me neither but they're
really the really crazy billing is
where'd weasels not getting rich from
this gig it's not like something playing
arenas and Zappa's music was never an
arena kind of thing you know it's a cult
thing and he's out for 20 years now or
whatever spreading the word of his
father's music it would be like if it
would be like if David Lee Roth's had a
son and then it all said he's like you
can't use Roth yeah what do you mean
that you're my dad yeah but Roth is van
hey
elin and you know they're putting the
kibosh on it or whatever it's just I
don't know there's numerous numerous
it'd be like like Jakob Dylan is one of
my best friend it'd be funny at like his
dad said you can't use the Dylan name
you know it's just absurd they're not
out making armies of money and that
family is already rich from the catalog
and the everything they own yeah yeah
it's just bad oh you know what I
actually do have a question why don't
you come into philly man oh man i wish i
was there this weekend you know as soon
as i get hooked or did you make it out
recent leave its pittsburgh right yep
that was the last spot i got pics berg
and that was because of Awesome death
squad ohio they they are amazing guys
drew it in death squad ohio everybody
out there they put that [ __ ] together
they're like we got to get Dean out here
cited Columbus Ohio and Pittsburgh in a
weekend but they put it together cuz
they wanted to see it awesome and it was
[ __ ] packed both shows great yeah
great so I oh you'll make it out here
man hope so man hope so me and spies to
get out there and and go clown that
Liberty Bell and I run the rock upstairs
and bother going to feed I saw it man
I'm in a glass case and it's you know I
was there you go online yeah I was here
but I will get some cheese steaks over
there shish boobles or whatever it's
called mr. Biddle yeah is capable haha
thank you for coming man amazing please
thanks bud all right brother later sit
anyway so Purple Rain yeah it's playing
over that that's that movie theater and
this mall they're rebuilding them all
right now the redoing of course there so
I get there first of all you pull into
this parking lot I don't even know where
the [ __ ] to go up it to get into the
place and walking all around the line
it's all construction zones those are
gelsons in there yep that I don't know
who the [ __ ] would go there too well let
me go to the word
small ever and grocery shot might get to
pay four dollars to park perfect it's
[ __ ] insane this mall so I go up some
escalator and I'm walking around and all
the shops are closed yeah at seven
because there's no one in too small
after six great business people went to
the Rolex stores closed that's the one
recently by the way that got robbed oh
yeah armed robbery with dudes actual
guns yeah yeah came and shot up the
joiner am all crazy then once I heard
that I go oh I realized why how they did
it they could just get away anyone in
this [ __ ] place so uh then I stumbled
into the Tesla store ok which was they
had the crew SUV one of the Goldwing
windows doors yeah look love that yeah
and then went into the movie theater
three people really three people in
purple rain huh because no one goes to
this movie theater yeah it's uh not for
that it's not known as like an art house
no place and also you just don't go
there because you park it I couldn't
find my [ __ ] after you know and I put it
down ago this I'm gonna be lost ya
anyway I go at purple rain and which by
the way the show to preview of kevin
hart's new concert film uh-huh you know
the football field in yeah it's pretty
great wow I just want to see it just to
see that you know yeah he's like we sold
this [ __ ] a football field in my
hometown what towns he from I don't know
yeah you know and i'll look it up i
don't know man whatever it was Stadium a
football stadium incredible and man look
cool as [ __ ] yeah I think you'd be
[ __ ] if you're Kevin Hart's feature
he's from Philly okay there you go so
you played where the Steelers are equal
egos oh oh yeah i'm thinking Pittsburgh
yeah Eagles um anyway you'd be [ __ ] if
you're Kevin Hart's opener or even amy
schumer's lately i'm working at amy
schumer it's just private jets yeah and
no one's there to see you yeah it'd be
polite but like everybody's getting
there be
but you're out there and you're going
like oh you're you have to the name of
the film i think is where do we go from
here or something and that would really
be your your your thing if you were the
feature yeah like okay man i'm not going
to tour this out this year so I gartner
do those open mics yeah I mean merrily
from from a football field to an open
mic I think I mean it is weird i don't
know and i don't mean any disrespect any
of these amazing comics and their
features I'm pretty well versed in
comedy and I can't name most of them I
don't know who most of these guys are
bringing with them consist on the road
we're not from the east coast right you
know what I mean that and I always find
that like I'll be like I don't know that
guy know and then you look up and go oh
this guys [ __ ] big on ya hope that
it's like Kevin's not touring that guy
or gal is headlining Caroline's
headlining you know coming in but yeah
isn't let it get so do it because so my
point is though it's gonna feel like an
open fire yeah I just need to 200,000 or
whatever yeah yeah and saying [ __ ] and
then so they showed the trailer for that
then right after they show another Kevin
Hart trail hahaha well him in the rock
yeah and I'm like how many movies all of
them this guy's in all the movies yeah
man grip a paper yeah speaking of
football fields not to left field we can
get back to purple rain to back yeah I
gotta get it uh the what is the [ __ ]
desert concert series gotcha old chela
uh yeah hmm I there were rumors are
gonna pull it off and it looks like
they're pulling off yeah I knew about
that like a month ago yeah and this was
like yeah of this night in a desert or
whatever they're calling it dude crazy I
don't give a [ __ ] what anyone says you
could try to clown all you want but if
you don't go out to that show the way
we're losing people right now yeah
you're out of your mind and and also the
egos of old men still rise up of all
right and so okay the first night
it's like the stones stones and like
what Neil Young or something there's a
dead it's like it's no stones dillman
Neil Young and and roger waters yeah
I'll they know who and McCartney oh yeah
set my guy whatever those the bands I
don't know the exact order but yeah I
think Neil Young's the last day yes Neil
Young a course has been crushing it all
year lately with this young band and
doing three-hour shows the only one
missing is Bruce I know man but in that
he's done though did you can't do you
know I think he can't come back so soon
after yeah but maybe would just go out
and win yeah but uh Roger Waters if you
haven't seen Roger Waters it's I don't
know what he's going to do this but last
two times I saw him one was dark side of
the moon he did the whole record and
then the next time he did the whole wall
record crazy if he came and did the
animals record I would lose my [ __ ]
mind the neil young's just murdering it
because the young he's letting the young
guys picked the setlist so they're
picking unbelievable [ __ ] off like on
the beach I've stones will do the stones
you know nothing on that [ __ ] desert
show full blown with the you know the
same tunes if it's not it's going to be
in October right so you can actually
tolerate sitting outside yeah it's not
going to be Coachella where you're like
this awesome oh my god i'm suffering
from I'm so dehydrated hopefully it's
not [ __ ] desert cold though man
didn't get cold out there and then the
who winding down there run which they
were great on Fallon yeah a couple weeks
ago and then McCartney who I've never
seen well every time I go to see him
somehow something happens or whatever so
I'll finally see him so this is gonna be
spectacular like those are the announcer
prizes like what do they do fly in Elton
John Bruce and Billy Joel anyway I'll to
kill yourself after this tour cuz you've
seen it all like me don't know who who
drops in Madonna I don't what
crazy oh you know crazy you know it's
funny too I forgot that I saw Prince add
[ __ ] Coachella huh I forgot he played
cocho like I've seen Prince so many
times out this this slowly comes to me
that keeps doing oh yeah I saw him there
yeah like any way that concerts gonna be
[ __ ] crazy I immediately put it in my
calendar and there's no way they're not
doing it two weekends in a row it's just
no I don't see how they can't yeah that
thing's just gonna sell it in one minute
yeah um anyway yeah so Purple Rain I sit
down and see it three people in the
theater felt like I said my own private
theater and it's incredible have you
seen it lately not lately okay I haven't
seen it probably in 20 years but before
I saw it in 85 of course I talked about
it and I watch it a bunch I haven't seen
in 20 years I know everyone haha it was
like Rocky Horror Picture Show or
something to me yeah like every time I
go to come in he would see your music
just like your father you know yeah no
good your music make no sense and I'm
doing I'm doing more stir in the corner
let's see some asses moving haha I'm
doing all the [ __ ] lines in the film
I mean that I couldn't believe how
embedded it was in my brain yeah like
goddamn i know this movie inside out and
not seen it for years it stands up so no
good and good like the look of course is
80s right but i love it there's a lot of
bowie s looking people in the crowd like
a kind of a you know painted faces and
that [ __ ] I seagulls hair do a lot of
white people in the crowd winners which
is hilarious I don't you know I
Minneapolis yeah right right first
avenue unbelievable and more stay just
crushing this [ __ ] film yeah
Apollonius boobs about my boobs
everything I remember so I got home and
I went down the rabbit hole of filming
this whole thing and it's an incredible
thing on rollingstone.com
the making of purple rain hmm I can't
even believe how cuz you got to think
how did this get made yeah he only has
the little red Corvette 1999 record out
he's not a giant star yet yeah course he
had a couple hits but they're not like
there's no one around Hollywood going in
let's uh yeah this is the guy let's make
a movie around this guy yeah but to read
what happens every a director turned it
down the script then every be director
turned it down and every see director
turned it down there was a guy coming
out of film school and he goes on I want
to read the script he reads it he goes I
want to have a meeting with rob cavallo
who was the producer huge record guy and
he says I know what your problem is the
script it's not happening you got to get
a script writer director to do it and he
goes what are you talking about he
pitches him us his idea yeah which is
look man he's he's got this bad family
and he's got this problems and all this
and he's like well I like that they fly
they meet Prince the next day's a guy
like that Rob's putting up a 500,000
print is putting up 500,000 when i read
that ago prince has 500,000 in 1983 or
whatever when they're talking about this
yeah they decide to shoot it but before
they do they meet with Warner Brothers
who's like they're like let's see if a
studio will get involved and we can get
more money out of them and their
directors like are you don't want to do
that they're going to try to [ __ ] it up
the first meeting Warner Brothers
because we like anything about this can
we get Travolta to play Prince that's an
actual [ __ ] statement can we get
Travolta to play Prince anyway a long
story short they Warner brother signs on
gives him seven million they shoot that
thing starting October thirty-first so
when she jumps in the water it's 10
degrees out freeze and the first day you
know the shots of him riding the
motorcycle and say that was the first
day of shooting after that snow
blizzards every
hahaha so all kinds of crazy [ __ ] but I
realized watching it last night two of
the greatest films ever made for me our
saturday night fever and purple rain and
both have John Travolta in them yeah
yeah but you know what i mean it's it's
so [ __ ] bad ass and he said the
director revealed that they want to do a
a sik asik a sequel right away after but
prince blew up so hard he was on tour
for two years yeah and then like seven
years later the graffiti bridge which
was kind of funky yeah but anyway what a
great film watch it it's just such a
simple story yeah and just so eager and
and hats off to the club owner the guy
that wears the white glass hahaha he's
so great he's like most a got a new girl
new girl group you better watch it kid
the kid his name's the kid yeah what a
film man what a film Morris Day man
crushing haha you got to see it yeah I
it's been back on my list especially
after Prince pass but its type of thing
where it's like because I have seen it I
keep a list of things I haven't seen
that I still need to see totally like I
still haven't seen Amy yeah so it's like
i know i need to see purple rain again
but [ __ ] i know this i betray we got
this matter of time here's another thing
i was tripping on what happened to abuse
I never understood how the inquirer
magazine works because they printed a
thing this week prince dies of AIDS yeah
and as I was reading this long lost
interview of Prince it just came out
today on Rolling Stone they interviewed
him in 2014 heavily in the interview
he's talking about how he doesn't need
anymore he doesn't eat really sometimes
four days five days straight he's
talking about how if you don't eat for a
while your body just doesn't crave it
anymore okay crazy stuff also talking
about how he has zero sex he's a
celibate and all this so you start to me
it seems like my point is out of this
inquire doesn't get sued
I thought if you put something out
people you just get sued but they just
put [ __ ] up but I think they just read
this article went oh he doesn't eat
doesn't have sex he's got AIDS I the
legality of it is longer more
complicated than to really dive into and
my knowledge of it also is fleeting with
every day that I don't practice law but
you know they just need a source yeah
and then you know they're reporting the
news that they heard so then yeah you
can sue them for it's like I believe
it's like they need to know that it's
false right like what effort did they do
to look into fact-check to independently
verify the things coming from this
source but seems like these tabloids are
just they're just [ __ ] trash it's
just brutal just there it is Prince dies
of AIDS right and then I people see that
[ __ ] at the man they just said he got
AIDS yeah yeah he was gay I knew it
whatever yeah now he's gay right you
know which first of all Charlie Sheen is
not gay yeah he's got AIDS yeah yeah I
made book middle of America yeah all the
sudden they just try to discredit okay
even if he did die of AIDS yeah greatest
songs ever one of the best performers
ever so what does it matter what he died
from yeah one of my buddies [ __ ] guy
is dead it sucks yeah tweet it out I
don't care how Prince died just I'm glad
that he lived yeah this weird thing was
it like I mean maybe there is a lesson
you can learn like if you something
tragic did happen he was addicted to
opioids or he did have age or something
like that then you can it can be a
rallying cry to people coming up in the
business now like hey look you got to
take care of yourself whether or
whatever I guess sometime it's like you
know I don't think he was [ __ ] kids
he wasn't killing people not like it's
not like there are some skeletons in his
closet it looks like that were oh no we
can't hold them up as a hero we filed up
far worse people still have buildings
named after people that owned other
people yeah i mean our country has a
pretty sword history yeah i think what
we know so far prince is a dude that we
can vault up on our shoulders and say
look at his [ __ ] cattle
log yep incredible the guy is humble
meal Oh which by the way when the guys
do in the movie yeah the songs it's not
like Prince head hey here's the Purple
Rain we're gonna have his he'll try his
vault like he does now probably had a
vault of a hundred songs but it wasn't a
record or when I was when I was young I
thought that he recorded the record and
then let's shoot the movie and we'll put
it out at the time that's what I thought
happened but really what happened was
the director said I need like a double
album you got one of these like no I'm
putting out a double album I guess well
we're going to i need songs that that
tell this story that I've row so he gave
Prince a hundred Prince gave him a
hundred songs on cassettes and he
listened to him and picked the songs on
and he goes I got it all but we need one
more song and he was hanging with prints
at rehearsal and they played purple rain
it was brand new and he goes what's that
song is I was brand-new his Purple Rain
and he goes and the band wrote it with
him which I didn't know just like the
movie the two girl and ever they do and
he said that's that's the [ __ ] song
and Prince goes let's call it purple
rain then and boom they named the movie
and everything right there yeah when I
said he still had that hundred songs so
she stored somewhere yeah you I'll try
to buy sign of the times on vinyl right
now in mint condition yeah right there
in the hundred now instantly yeah oh I
told you this update update I bought my
second autograph Oh [ __ ] you're talking
about buying autograph oh I I stand by
this I tweeted out though that this is
the every all the best bands are going
on tour this year if you're 35 years or
older like it is like but all these
bands are going back and so I'm a big
pop punk guy in blink 182's putting out
a new records they going on to her
they're huge summer tour the weird dudes
back in no Tom's gone Oh GABA Skiba
hurry say his last name he still don't
them for years and he's on the record
and going on tour with them and they
released one song bored to death
sounds like sounds like blink anyway
they put out there putting out their new
record comes out in July and for me it
was just like they have a purple vinyl
yeah it is beautiful looking of the new
record and then like a bundle with that
with this dope hoody that's just very
basic it's a zip up hoodie has their
logo one on the back the logo is kind of
like a zombie dude like a grimed kind of
guy or whatever drive anika looks like
an old Cadillac or something and I'm
like that's [ __ ] awesome buddy that's
a [ __ ] awesome vinyl I got to get
those those are things are going to get
and then like the only way you could get
it was like special edition purple vinyl
signed by the band and of course it's
like 20 bucks more than like the black
vinyl in the hoodie but I was just like
[ __ ] so I bought an autograph I
like to think i bought a purple vinyl
yeah but you couldn't get it yeah an
autograph that's there that's the story
if you come over to my house and you see
my sign yeah blink record hey did you
meet them no I did being a rolling stone
though there is a crazy article about
Tom DeLonge who was the guy that's not
with the band on this on this record
that he seems come on dude what happened
to that guy UFO obsession really it's
he's like releasing all these like books
and [ __ ] and like his new record is tied
into UFOs and he started to angels and
airwaves and he did like press for that
as a cab and he's like we're gonna be
like you too but bigger oh yeah now he
says that he was on painkillers when he
said that angel dust and haha it is so
talented even unlike the Angels and
Airwaves released a new EP and it still
has some of the catchiest simplest
guitar licks in it like the dude is just
a talent right but something wasn't he
the singer him and the bass player yeah
they didn't mark and Tom both sing but I
like to think of this tour as do you
like blink 182's dude ranch well here's
one dude from that record because Travis
is an incredible drummer but he wasn't
there first yeah I think goes after dude
ranch he came on yeah so it's like one
original guy from blink yeah no travel
have a three-piece yeah yeah I gotta try
this recently remember he prayed with a
[ __ ] uh auntie mass dude incredible
oh I got crushing and he said
do the podcast just disappeared well
he's kind of busy apparently they were
recording a [ __ ] blink album in
secret yeah also it came out on this
that their last I know I'm excited for
this new album because I'm listening to
their last album neighborhood it's not
good I mean it's fine but it sounds like
angels and airwaves and apparently they
didn't they weren't in the same studio
Oh Tom recording from San Diego yeah no
wonder if just email me the trucks do
not get along yeah there just weren't
and then like Travis apparently was like
well [ __ ] I was gonna play tracks in my
gen so it's like this weird no chemistry
yeah 3 piece bad should be recording
live for sure yeah i mean the easiest
and now this new album they've all been
together and the first song bored to
death sounds sounds good i'm i am
optimistic did you like heavier the new
radiohead today I haven't I saw that it
dropped I saw your tweet like everybody
says they like it but they secretly hate
it well secretly deep inside and and
this is funny too i tweeted that 35 year
olds rejoice it's the summer us that bad
tweet is exploding by the way people
love it but people love it I hurt my
shoulder not on 35 do my shorts sorry go
ahead um the people are jumping on it
for the wrong wrong ways I hate when
people like first of all I love radio
yeah i love the band's record ok
computer and [ __ ] kid a and even in
rainbows and i like i like that really i
think it's kind of cool okay you know I
even like the stuff that Johnny did for
they'll be brought yes do you know yeah
that's great so people like yeah I never
liked that bad but your [ __ ] ball
about you down I'm like now I know
you're wrong there they're [ __ ] great
but they're not on the plateau that I
think everybody like no one will say bad
about him and I'm not saying that what
I'm saying is like but some of these
records are just filler stuff man
they're just it's just no tunes like if
the bends you know you got fake plastic
trees that's a [ __ ] song you hear it
you remember it you know it's
in your head you're like what a crafted
[ __ ] masterpiece like the verve you
know bittersweet symphony so a song yeah
and a lot of those British bands had so
many great songs Oasis Radiohead the
verb beware all those whose songs yeah
and of course I get Radiohead goes into
some exploratorium area Pink Floyd is
kind of i'm not i remember one at one
point I was in New Orleans for voodoo
fest I was in a record store and a guy
was playing this music I said [ __ ] is
this the new radiohead and he has no
this is the syd barrett solo records and
I was like wow talk about that they've
been listening to that yeah I mean I
bought both of said that day but yeah I
understand you going to your pink floyd
thing but now it's just kind of like
there's no song there today I'm
listening it's just a flat line do do do
do you know we could play a second of it
I'm not saying yeah but you'd have to
look it up though so don't Apple music
but it's you know and there's this
hipster site talking about oh man the
violins sound like something out of you
know like a Apocalypse Now or it's in
the witch burn the witch and so plugging
in yeah check it out
play like 15 seconds so don't get sued
standard Radiohead and I'm going to
scrub forward
you
you know all right gonna stop it it's
just feels fine by don't think if you
singing along to that well there's no
real hook yeah I'm like where's the
course where's the [ __ ] yeah it's a
short song like three minutes I'm like
there was no hook maybe that's what we
need though like I've always appreciated
bands like Radiohead and back where I
feel like forcing the conversation of
what music is at the time to go a
different way because I feel like so
much pop right now and and rihanna's
what's her new one unmasked whatever
news one's a little different but the
good time tour I feel like a lot of that
pop yeah only had hooks I think we
talked about it like I get that I guess
like hook but these guys have done this
thing for a while now yeah it's just
kind of like here's some song I tell you
I right sounds like that all the time
you know you're just like yeah it
doesn't really go anywhere when you
listen back to them back yeah yeah even
if it doesn't have a hook like I'm not
saying the hook but like some structure
of like some kind of like look even when
you listen to pink floyd animals yeah
it's got all the structure and crew like
the mattock stuff you know anna and i
could be talking about my ass because a
month for now i could be like god it's
great but that's the beauty of music
yeah you thought before like great
attended a yeah yeah yeah and then your
tastes change if you love it and you're
listening and you love Radiohead just
because Dean says he's not digging it
right now doesn't mean you're wrong
absolutely and liking it not at all I
love the new blink 182 song you might
hate it that's fine my point is if
you're just liking it because you're
afraid that people don't think you're
cool then you're a [ __ ] idiot that's
my whole point of this whole that tweet
yeah that's the whole point there's tons
of people out there that I believe when
you're at a party oh yeah you a new
radio own Crabill huh like you would
have asked me right now and even though
I hadn't heard it I would have said yeah
dude is no man
god is god man you know what I mean and
if you really feel like I don't really
like that Thun but you don't say it that
is just so [ __ ] high school yeah yeah
afraid of like I don't wanna not look
cool we like that right it's the thing
with I we are down right you know it's
like I believe a lot of people own
Radiohead and don't listen I've seen it
I've seen Radiohead six times I own
their records here's my sealed kitteh I
mean it's a little because i don't like
them listen to it but look at that
sealed kid ass but i think they've come
do with a thing work oh that's their
sound yeah like if they may be did an
acoustic record assume I even like the
last thing Tom did his solo stuff that
[ __ ] was cool it was really [ __ ]
weird you know this video is weird where
he's [ __ ] dance oh yeah yeah I like
that [ __ ] you know so don't get me wrong
I'm not up I don't like how people
jumped on it in the wrong way like yeah
that they're not music they'd never be
getting me all that like you're so wrong
I've been always been good but there's a
lot of filler in there yeah and I'm not
really sure i think when bands explode
as big as they do i don't think it's
your necessarily your number one thing
anymore in life once they had kids and
stuff like oh yeah we'll get that thing
going in three years you know yeah it's
hard it we listen to louis ck bill
simmons interview yeah a couple weeks
ago and still out there on his podcast
great amazing and Louie talks about the
cliq economy for like online and how
things are shared and what things you
know are said and listen to the
interview i'm not going to recap it but
I feel like where we are now with like
Radiohead how it applies to that it's
like you're either seeing the think
pieces about how great it is or it's
[ __ ] home and there's never anyone in
the like you're not allowed to just be
like it's good yeah like its font you
you know dude this is either the bitter
like [ __ ] radio yeah yeah weird world
where like if you just think something's
okay yep like the internet mob or
whoever were like jump on you big how do
you think it was okay or I'll try to
pull you all the way to yeah [ __ ] radio
megadeth only it's like well yeah Megan
that's great that's what's crazy that's
what happened they jumped on this thing
I can't man [ __ ] punch [ __ ] am I he's
one of us he hates up my guitar on
you're missing the point of that tweet
was if you don't like it and don't admit
it you're an idiot yeah not once did I
say I didn't like it in the tweet or
anything I said right you know radiohead
released a new song today and
everybody's running around saying it's
amazing but deep inside they don't like
it you know that's the point of yeah of
hipster stuff and and and people also
jump on and try to [ __ ] on hipsters and
and like I said many times I love
hipsters they're any good music there's
always going to be a great record store
and coffee shop in that hipster
neighborhood and yeah and beautiful
girls ever style yeah style girls would
stop there no joining a century city
yeah like last night that uh met gala
was some of the worst clothing I've ever
seen I'd rather see Karen Oh any time on
stage she had more style than any of
those women last night just wearing
their c-3po outfits and looking so phony
man it's so bummer what's going on there
I don't get high fashion so I'll be the
first to say I'm out of my water or out
of my element but what I don't
understand about it is these people
these men and women I feel like they
don't dress like this reg they don't
seem into high fashion either there's
like oh this is the thing where we do
this thing and then the stylist is like
this is the thing that you wear I'd
rather see Shia LaBeouf walking around
in uggs cut off daisy dukes and a tank
top because that's what he [ __ ]
where's samples same word Kim Kardashian
every photo her she's in sweatpants yeah
and then never ever yeah but the point
is so weird it's like the girls in to me
in in silverlake or most fearless right
now have more flavor than any of those
women last night and Taylor Swift who I
think is a beautiful woman choosing look
herself anymore it's so weird I was like
who is that I couldn't even see her in
there yeah I was a being pictures like I
don't even know who that is anymore
she's only like 20 something you know
yeah it's weird and lady gaga I don't
even know what's going on there I think
she that's fine no no that's her shes
supposed to look crazy that's your thing
but her outfit wasn't even cool yeah I
mean yeah that's her comment maybe yeah
I don't get it I don't I don't I just
don't understand and I get it like if I
go to a dodgers game I'll wear my
dodgers jersey yeah I'm not always
wearing my dot so maybe it's that you go
to the met gala and you just dress
[ __ ] crazy and that uh what you do
but then they seem so self serious about
it oh yeah a Dodgers game I'm like let's
go [ __ ] it yeah you know but the other
like it's insane it's weird oh my god
fits were insane what can you be like
yeah I look like a [ __ ] mirror yeah
any word let you do a itself seriousness
about and that one that's all the one
girl on the runway she was wearing like
a like a beaver skeleton unbelievable
I'm really you know who looked
incredible oh my god and in just
complete class and style which is funny
because his head Margaret Cho on the
podcast and she's not fashion pois now I
feel like we're fashion babies right now
but Sean Penn's daughter okay oh my god
then her name's Dylan Penn we can look
at I am Dylan Penn on Instagram because
I was trying to look at the different
outfits and I was like who's this girl
yeah oh my god Sean Penn's daughter 25
spectacular just classy rockin yeah she
looked amazing man yeah hats up there
but Madonna like I don't know what she
was doing it's like a great man
unbelievable and you know what more
power to them but i think that like
there's just like like I could go to
meltdown and the girls look way cooler
than any of those girls I've said it a
million times they just have flavor and
style it's personal style versus you
should wear this yep exactly and that's
all money
yeah generated like let's put this out
and people you know and then they they
they go broke from [ __ ] win [ __ ]
that's only good for like a week right
you know let's grab this call hey what's
happening you're on the air hey Dean and
Christian how you doing that who's
calling this is scott from san diego how
are you SD in the house did you come to
the shows i did indeed my wife and i
were front row on the Friday Late Show
Wow as a good show thanks for coming
great time we enjoyed both you guys set
it was tremendous thank you thank you no
you're the guy who was first thing shall
I think yeah is that okay if she really
from China or is that I'm really well
he's it caused enough he's a blonde
white guy yep totally blind he's a got
no it's legit legit him man yeah he's a
be he was tremendous too yeah it
wouldn't even matter if it was any
common thing either way you'd be like
well i left the United meant great but
yeah that is him and follow him on
twitter ID he's dumb I need to tell him
to fix this thing because it's some like
thing you can't find yeah something like
eighty eighty Cheng Chao 8080 or
something I yeah I don't even know how
to find him in tagging [ __ ] yeah why did
you thanks for coming dude good time is
it was really fun i wanted to because i
don't know what you guys are talking
about this afternoon so I'm just going
to throw a question at you and see what
you get have you you guys you know rub
up against elbows with celebrities and
stuff every once in a while working
where you do have you ever met someone
that you admired and like fault like you
totally blew the you know you blew the
meeting you you kind of made a fool of
yourself for that starstruck or
something like that well I get pretty I
said over and over I get pretty
starstruck not starstruck but around
Louie because I just don't see him a lot
yeah and he's my favorite comedian so
when I do see him I'm I don't want to be
that guy where I hit him with a hundred
questions but I have hundreds of
questions forum you know and
mostly just out of like oh god I love
this guy's TV comedy and and everything
about them so it's always kind of weird
I just keep it short like hey what's
going on you know and check one question
off the list each year because he's so
nice you know but I don't want to just
be like this weirdo you know but like I
mean what's that inside you're like I
inside you like I want to sit down and
talk to you for an hour but I gotta be
real about it well he's like a dream
podcast guest you know he does he's done
a bunch of podcast and of course there's
standard questions but to me he's the
reason I started comedy so I would have
way different questions you know and I
was used to be like that around burr I
think once you're around guys you
realize their regular humans and i found
that 99% of the comedians are the nicest
dudes ever so it once they realized that
you're working hard and doing the [ __ ]
there they open up and hang and [ __ ] you
know that's spice I've told so I mean I
I think I've told on here i know i have
my bill burr story like that was like a
treat in that moment where i was in my
career were like he was giving me
compliments on my set from stage and
then I knocked over a table which sucked
walking off stage and then I saw Tom
Cruise once and I just had this moment I
wasn't like hobnobbing with them
whatever it just like happened to be in
the same physical space as he was
walking by and it was one of those
things where I do like a double take and
like uncontrollably out of my mouth this
one oh [ __ ] that's Tom Cruise yeah and
he looks back and he goes yeah I get the
nicest smile and I was just like well I
just talked to Tom cruising yeah I did
that the same thing I did that too Lily
went like six months ago he hadn't been
around the store in a while and he came
in i was sitting in the bucket seats
getting ready to go on and look just out
of my mouth when will we
yeah yeah it's like inside me I was like
oh [ __ ] Louise you know like oh he's
going on yeah well we were at the store
I don't know how long ago this was but
you were talking to mark and I was
sitting there kind of like talking I
don't know I'm new as well as you do
yeah but you know we're all in this
conversation but then I was talking to
someone else I was off in the corner and
they're like you looked like you were
just dead in the eyes Christian what
you're doing I was like well I was in
this conversation but like I I feel I
feel like I know mark because all of us
feel like we know him because we've
listened to him for thousands of hours
but like so as I'm listening to him in
real life I'm thinking about the catalog
i have in my head of him and I'm just
like man he's the coolest guy in the
world okay be present in this
conversation be present in this
conversation and another guy so I was
like yeah you just looked like dead on
my head my face was just like what's
happening yeah it's crazy you know
because I said it over and over comedy
is unlike anything in the world comedy
is where the stars and the beginners
work in the same rooms there's no
there's no rock bands where we're like
the rock bands playing and then you know
when they're done 10 other bands go on
after and the hang back stage you know
and there's no movies with just you know
like brand new guys to LA like in a
movie all the sudden with you know Tom
Cruise yeah but comedy you're at the
store and you're doing an open mic and
then boom there's bill burr or Rogan or
Maron or any of the guys and if you're a
brand new comic you're like holy [ __ ]
those are probably the reasons these
people do comedy yeah thanks for calling
man yeah man you bet I could never do
what you guys do I totally admire it
thank you so much DP thanks man all
right we got another call let's grab it
hey what's up be there oh hey what's up
E what's happening who's this it's your
boy been out of coupon man yeah a Tucson
been TB what's up that man what do you
got it done today we're just talking uh
well we're just talking about all kinds
of stuff you know anything you got any
questions today no not really i was
listening to bitching from last week you
guys were talking about bees and
everything and i also got all
I'm always hesitant to sell milk is like
you're saying I mean you at least you
found a place where they gave me some
money for all right well I sound like
that whole thing were like I'm using
that much either anymore but don't worry
you're rid of them on oh well I find if
you go to a suburb store I think you're
going to get more money than a hipster
big big store because the smaller stores
that's why they survived by use product
they're not just stacking their shelves
with brand new you know they don't want
to buy like 25 Radiohead record you know
what I mean or whatever any brand new
stuff it's better just to fill it with
you stuff that they bought for way
cheaper so you know I think if you find
certain stores which by the way spicer I
forgot to tell you I was cleaning out
working on the house more yesterday and
found another case of dvds i forgot
that's where the lucky Louie DVDs were
yeah anyway you know I think it comes to
a point like spicer and I was saying you
got [ __ ] in your house you you haven't
[ __ ] looked or used it in years out
of there yeah it's the point like when
is the last time you moved and when are
you moving again and I feel like that is
often for me an impetus for getting rid
of [ __ ] yeah well you like yeah i love
these boxer CDs but [ __ ] i had to run a
u-haul because i have all these boxes of
cds yeah i haven't opened since the last
time I moved ten of the boxes when I was
moving or CDs and DVDs and books yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy you know I was
thinking about back in the day whenever
I was good traveling I would bring you
know my all my clothes and then I
literally have a whole other [ __ ] bag
full of one and a bunch of CDs yeah [ __ ]
and books man yeah Brooks way thousands
of pounds they need [ __ ] you know they
need to be [ __ ] like I got all these
cool books like killer coffee table
books and [ __ ] and my copy of Jaws yeah
I got your job absolutely I got it and
it's just I kept it mint no he's on it
it's right next to the stereo I'll bring
you this week um but yeah
you're just kind of like [ __ ] these
books i love them but i don't even I'm
such a weirdo I keep my [ __ ] mint don't
even like to look at the Blessed cuz I
don't like the pictures to be dead haha
how [ __ ] wait am I like look at this
Zeppelin coffee table book that we got
it don't look at don't you look at me
thanks for calling man huh oh yeah yeah
for sure man go ahead man oh no I was
just gonna say you know I I think it's
probably highly unlikely but you know
how cassettes kind of came back in a
very small way only film in in here like
glad I sold it what that I had a stack
of cassettes about a year ago about 200
them and sold him when the hipsters were
getting into that and man i'm so glad i
did it right then cuz they've already
dropped off of it I knew it was going to
be a short window I just wonder if
that's gonna happen with CDs I highly
doubt it but you kind of never know you
know what I mean like when stuffs gonna
come back around sometimes I'm really
surprised yeah but what are you gonna do
need to go back around you they're not
gonna get rich yeah i mean like but
there's way more cds in the world than
there was cassettes cassettes are
[ __ ] hard for there's five billion
concede he's out there you know yeah I
know well I was always hope that many
discs we're going to take off I liked
about them is that they had the sound
quality of a CD but they had that really
nice hard plastic housing yeah I could
toss them across a room and they would
actually do okay no the only thing
worthwhile about cassettes is that they
could really [ __ ] kicked out of them but
that was about the only thing so it
sounded pretty crappy yeah they're
pretty good for chopping coke up on
Terra you know cars okay I'm also
pre-rolled joints and put them in a sec
just a sec yeah thanks dude are you here
later let's get out of here I gotta go
meet a Santa Ana uh if you're listenin
I've but if not it'll be already done
but i'll be at the store all this
weekend Friday Saturday Sunday main room
an original room were you I I don't know
okay cool Salt Lake City sandy stations
headlining there on the 21st of this
month is a road out of town of doing cup
of alt shows that thursday and friday
before but i'm headlining that saturday
may 21st well i'll be in reno in salt
lake city ok we know
night that made 17 through the 22nd
silver legacy Laugh Factory and jun 28
through july second the return five
nights headlining comedy works thanks
guys leave the reviews donations on
patreon.com / Dean Del Rey and I'm Dean
Del Rey on Twitter snapchat and
Instagram spicer at Spicer on twitter is
the best way to get in touch with me you
can find everything else at my website
Christian Spicer com see you guys thanks
for tuning in